estudios de pregrado en ingeniería o
en ciencias o estudios
estudios de doctorado en medicina parece ser el
carta de triunfo que debes tener
incluso antes de considerar solicitar el
primera vez que ella es el comité
selección del agente de personal que van a
vemos a una persona porque a
a través del proceso si miramos y
privarnos de exámenes médicos
expediente médico
pero es la primera vez que van
debe a nadie es como en derecho
y reirán nos verán
originalmente de rouyn noranda asi que en el norte
de quebec
otro quebequense podría ser el
próximo astronauta de la agencia espacial
canadiense
charles philippe se unió al trabajo
actualmente como científico
de los instrumentos astronómicos a las TIC
baltimore por lo tanto en los estados unidos en el
proyecto telescopio espacial james webb
dirigidos ambos por la agencia de la nasa
agencia y espacio canadiense
espacio europeo
Tuviste la oportunidad de ver el
libro de esfuerzos y medios que uno todos
los dominios de la vida en el momento ya que
su club solo busca gente
que son bien lógicos marineros o los
universidad de geología y ya que viene de todos
las áreas que le dan a toda esta gente
se evaluará en el mismo
penurias no podemos decir mas porque
que en un año 90 años de confianza y la
precio pero me han pesado lo quiero
muy interesante para alguien que ama
que mueren duro los desafíos
tecnológico
por lo tanto, el agente espacial canadiense lanzó
una convocatoria de solicitudes el verano pasado
para reclutar dos nuevos astronautas
de gira por encima de 3000 cuando llegó
el jefe de proyecto de la
campaña de contratación de agencias
el espacio canadiense karlstad indica esto
dos candidatos entre los 3700
solicitudes inicialmente recibidas para
hacer su sueño realidad
estamos en nuestra cuarta campaña del
último lugar en 2008 y tenía
también preceden de la misma manera en este
momento en el límite todo aún no es
perfecto como de hecho tenemos en cuenta
ahora de la omnipresencia de los medios
social era era la manera con
cual se promociona a la campaña de
reclutamiento
queremos asegurarnos de que las personas que tienen
a quién conoceríamos entonces más
Aplicar
sí sueño con hacer desde que era pequeño
soñé con el informe de anoche
alexander cooper king en busca de trabajo
doctorado en física atómica en
el instituto de tecnologia
california es uno de los candidatos
elegido por la agencia espacial
canadiense para ser parte del
lista corta
el canadiense pidió a los candidatos que
sigue las instrucciones eran para mi
hacerlo y tuve la idea en el
tiempo para poder servir a Canadá y
si es posible ir al espacio para
sigue experimentando
científicos y posiblemente también
ir a marte
por lo que de hecho se une a la idea de
exploración por lo tanto hay exploración
intelectual y que significa para el
veces así que trata de averiguar
cosas nuevas pero también
para ir a lugares que nunca han
sido explorado por ejemplo el planeta
mano pero si cuando el ter - yo la pared
nueve y no teniente coronel jeremy
hansen, piloto de 41 años en el
Canadian Forces es hoy una
de los otros tres nuestros canadienses dentro
de los 47 contados actualmente por la nasa
hizo muchas cosas bien
aflojar
podemos saltarnos los exámenes para
prueba de mama para ver cómo estos
gente
bach y ancianos en situacion
el proyecto sobre el estanque de dibujo en este
momento por lo tanto prevé misiones
humanos a la luna hasta 2030 y
posteriormente a Marte los astronautas
Canadienses sobre todo además de
los diplomas deben tener como calidad
alcance principal de la paciencia
el espacio es el objetivo final de un
carrera y puede tomar años
que desde hace tres años soy un poco
desaparecidos en la escuela astronautas
diferentes capacitaciones completadas allí
necesita un punto de pilotaje para eca robotics
como hacer paseos espaciales
a usar el traje espacial aprende por el
rusos el quebecois david saint-jacques
supo en 2016 que él sería el
próximo astronauta canadiense en visitar
la estación espacial internacional en
el día que me contrataron no estoy
de repente se convirtió en un astronauta que
toma años años para uno
cambiar un poco la casa creemos que podemos
imagina tal vez un poco como un
mezcla entre volver a la universidad
y luego tal vez convertirse en piloto al mismo tiempo
es hora de volverse un poco como un militar
en el sentido de que estamos en un
estructura topper una mezcla de todos
astronautas somos somos la parte la
más visible desde un inmenso y que
que sigo teniendo 29 con una tez claro
el quebequense daniel desjardins
originario de gaspésie era
cortarlo recientemente por razones
médico lo que tenemos dos veces después
haber vivido en manos mías un intercambio suyo
banco por no poder continuar con esto
ya sea coincidencia en la parte superior de mi queja o
para ver el lado positivo y eso es seguro
sólo al final del día cuando continuamos
nuestros sueños no nos arrepentimos de nada
así que no me arrepiento de haber sido
creció a partir de esta experiencia y él
Estoy muy feliz de verte de nuevo.
tarifas el año pasado buen pelo uno
informe de radio canada internacional